in a few years these medical students
will be the first graduates of newly
built Deborah bahan University two hours
drive from the Ethiopian capital Addis
Ababa Deborah bahan is one of 23 new
universities that have been built in
Ethiopia since 2007 this young doctor
was happy to be able to attend a
university in his hometown I'm just
around this done so I need to be near to
my family and that would be very nice to
me too sure to use the first place to
university Ethiopia's government set
itself an ambitious goal to double the
number of university graduates within
five years the scheme was funded mainly
with money from its own coffers but a
question remains other students really
getting a good education as a medical
student we have some gaps right in the
lab of the care equipment seized and
books as a very big league but when it
comes year to year it's very very in
advance and the gaps are filled time by
time lectures in Deborah bahan began in
2007 when many of the buildings were
still in the construction eight years
later they're finished those signs
indicate that some areas are already in
need of repair in addition to inadequate
buildings there's a shortage of trained
teaching staff only eight percent of the
lectures have their doctorates many of
them are receiving further training but
their average age is under 30 they lack
experience to pass on to the students
the Dean of the medical faculty says
Ethiopia simply doesn't have enough
academics he himself is only 28 years
old
there is a lack of specialists adequate
number of specialized in our country
David special and the other thing as a
result of infrastructure in the lack of
teaching hospitals so that the
specialists were not interested to be
instructed in the gramercy with the help
of five-year plans and government
investment Ethiopia wants to become a
middle-income country by 2025 but for
that it needs more trained skilled
workers the education minister says that
in future industry not farming must be
the linchpin of the economy when we
reach at least two lower middle-income
country the industry will be leading the
economy at least it will start leading
the economy by then more number of
science graduates are required under
more number of social science graduates
1.3 billion euros a quarter of the
entire budget is being invested in
higher education Ethiopia are not donor
countries is providing most of the money
its politicians say it's an investment
in the future most of the donors are
focusing on basic occasion but for the
country like ours and other developing
countries the focus or tertiary
education is also very important if the
country has to live despite that the
country's opposition says the money
isn't being invested properly they in a
pet roses leader of the Opposition and
he himself taught at the University of
Addis Ababa for 40 years he sees major
problems in Ethiopia's education system
from the outside it looks like you know
but rather a very responsible kind of
thing to do but this is westley this
country cannot afford waste the limited
resources in the name of expanding which
is politically driven populists petrol
says constructing universities is not an
investment in the future but more than
anything a job creation scheme
by the remote unstable provinces my
proposal would be consolidation that is
to add quality into these institutions
we have to create some centers of
excellence okay not every universe so
called university should open every
aspect of education youth unemployment
in Ethiopia lies at an estimated fifty
percent so it's questionable whether a
growing number of university graduates
can find work but the government is
optimistic it believes the education
initiative will soon create growth and
jobs